we're here with the official Black Adam
character breakdown from injustice to
now this was taken from nether realms
live stream but since the game comes out
next Tuesday May 16th be sure to hit
that subscribe button to stay up to date
with all the latest on DC's premier
fighting game so blackout is back he is
a defensive powerhouse just like he was
a part one
he plays pretty similar I think we were
all pretty happy with his design so
don't fix what's not broke
right like he he really fits in the
injustice engine he basically has a
great walk back great range the meter
burn low lines of Hispanic on a damage
like magic is back it's still a really
good combo starter right and that's
something that's new combo normal
sidekick is back you can come a normal
in that yeah oh really you don't need a
meter broom that that's it you got freed
up full screen it's really good to meet
a bird because then you can hear
lightning right I miss right it is good
yeah he's back to his banner it's still
really good overhead and it goes into
these fun moves yeah all the follow ups
are still there at whether in the air
I'm really glad blackout in fact he was
actually when I when I used to be in QA
was the first character that I played
with yes he still has his eye thick
which is super fast it launches them
Aaron you've been playing blackout a lot
lately what would you say are the big
changes to its gameplay um one of my
favorite things about him is actually
his new move if you want to show that
off it's dancing hi the second hits mid
third hits an overhead all that's Vidar
safe so you can you know you don't have
to complete it you don't have you can
stop whenever you want
but yeah it's extremely fast if you
wanted to show the range on it it hits
from like you know really far away so
it's really good for punishing unsafe
stuff that has a lot of pushback what's
that mean cold I don't know speaks yeah
there you go
I'm like four one two three yes you know
while he's walking back making you with
you want to come into him and you know
you miss you're gonna lose a lot of life
right maybe maybe I could maybe I could
add alright let's do this let's do okay
this is called what is this called a
Tyler Lansdowne can I complete a combo
in five times so we're gonna ask the
chat how many tries will take me Cletus
comma three for me like you you guess
seven whoa
Burke says to thank you this I would say
for me right now played it very much is
a 5 out of 10 on the scale
I want to change from Mighty then what
do you think six six two two six
he just prices right in me oh come on
all right so you're upset here we go we
got four or five million not we're not
gonna try that many times eight three
four I'm gonna say I'm gonna say - can I
get an answer
yeah yeah I'm not watching the other
screen to do it here we go right no it's
still it's an 11
oh you're right the first party on the
first venison you got this then the
Mississippi game yeah got worked out
which are over done pretty cool though
right
yeah what we've seen so far is cool okay
well you see where it is any of us even
dropping it he's doing 40% so black out
of hits really hard this game right
and another nice thing about that is
obviously his overhead is still one of
his his back - is one of his core moves
people want to block high all the time
so I'll be walking back so that long
range high lets you you know check
people with that all the time if you
cancel and do this trade it's a very
advantageous situation off of that
here's your sorrows basically back he
don't stretch out and then the opponent
basically can't do much of all he can go
in and get the damage and if they go on
an attack him they're gonna take the
damage and those are his accessory as
well so yes there's a ton of different
types of order some get really cool and
I'm hoping that's not promise we might
show some really cool gear tomorrow
during the gear screen that has
something to do with those works some
baby stuff we'll see what happens we'll
you'll be here so you won't be out
that's fine so black black Adam you know
like we talk about legacy characters
really still sort of he maintains if you
play black adding does may obtain a
symbols of what you knew with a new
really cool advancing move right he kind
of state there's a lot of them did stay
a bit the same but in plays so if you
played in you can play him again very
well yeah I think fans a black Adam that
really liked this play style the
original are gonna be very happy it's
right it's everything you liked and then
he has a new toy to play with very very
strong and it really complements what
made him a powerful carry from the first
game that new advanced EMU is really
good
it also looks absolutely awesome yeah
let's just keep the shout out to that to
the riddle of the Sphinx this affects
our knees I think they might be my
favorite so real of the Sphinx we should
we tell the real sings story sure ok so
back when we're in QA I was in QA and I
used to create a file that would have
combos that I came up with or nowhere is
good at anybody else's but I want to
have a file for myself so I would always
name them something cool right so my
Black Adam combo was called riddle of
the Sphinx yeah and then I send it
around their way and said hey everybody
check out riddle of the Sphinx um and
that's when Steve beside you thought I
was okay yeah you know first knowing you
I didn't really know you don't well
right that's how people start right that
was the moment around like this guy
literally names combos something more
but you know not not big damage combo
right lower base names and then runs
around the QA lab demanding everyone
look at the videos this guy I like this
guy I don't notice them demanding it so
much you think maybe the realist thinks
is why it dilemma knows well we actually
know the answer that yeah when the flash
two beds you three go it's man right
okay you guys you notice there's two
different supers where Egyptian
monuments are destroyed
oh man did you like this in the second
one let's do it
[Music]
that was awesome that's so cool let's
talk about some of the gear shall we
let's talk about loadouts so let's say
you like Black Adam but you want to kind
of freshen up his play style you want to
make your own version of Black Adam
right his abilities are very very
interesting first we gave him a t-bolt
which this tracks anywhere is very very
quick in the Lederberg version pops the
button so this replaces the blackett the
black magic is basically enhanced for is
enough like that so you're getting a
black magic for a better or like
fullscreen then we give him power of at
our hands how is that pronounced a now
Michael you actually know that I think
it's a town a town this replaces is well
off low lightning and it's an incredibly
fast be the meter verdun meter one is a
fish of the damage it's a high but it's
very very it's pretty much instant and
it's multiple bit so if they like trying
to arm or something we're going to get
blown up yeah I don't think so Batman
then plan for that prepare for this also
that you're not always pretty drink yeah
that okay alright so one more low down
mmm all right so first we gave them he
is obviously a character the dominate
stick whoa that's nice yeah right right
someone was actually asking about that
recently they would once in ok I could
not talk about it and here you go I
believe we showed you the stream while
back actually movie going well it's so
cool these two brought twice sure there
you go no Kate so his air mobility is
obviously one of the key things that
makes
good we gave him an air lightning cage
so at any point you can just drop down
and it's still a combo starter has the
exact same properties and it's super
fast so you can kind of mix up doing a
jump in doing the air cage and doing the
dodging so it's get another option with
his irritability let some control the
air a little more than he was right base
by him and then lastly he actually has a
couple abilities that give a whole new
character power and this one's really
cool it's actually a tribute to the late
Billy Batson he gets Billy's Shazam's
character power all of his punches now
do increase damage so love Suzanne so if
you're an offensive player and you don't
you're like you know what I love black
Hannah but I'm in Yolo in-your-face kind
of guy you can use this one is a little
buff all your pumpkin seeds pretty know
so can you shut the or oh you can't kiss
nothing dead but really cool love this
one but they won't be there Oh we'll see
those in the game comes out my dad so
that's just the sample odds abilities
use a few more than it means moves and
different brand new moves all right
awesome
let's uh let's do while you're setting
up for the Clown Prince of Crime the
Joker well there's some birthday shout
outs so this is generally a Dericks job